okay good evening everyone
I'd like to welcome you're here I'm
purchase drow I'm the Dean of the School
of Engineering and I'd like to thank you
all for joining us here tonight not only
do we have a full house here in NVIDIA
auditorium but we're streaming this
event to alumni students and Friends
around the world so we are here to honor
Marcion better known as Ted Hoff who was
the architect of the first
microprocessor released in 1971 and I
think it's no exaggeration to say the
Ted's work and all that it led to
revolutionized modern life now let me
just say a few words about our
engineering Heroes program it was
launched in 2010 and it recognizes the
achievements of Stanford engineers who
have really made tremendous advances in
the course of human social and economic
progress through engineering we have 32
heroes to date and they really embody
all that the school stands for
innovation entrepreneurship leadership
and world-class teaching and research
along with Ted this year's inductees are
andrey andy akarova so renowned chemical
engineers and software pioneers charles
Simoni creator of i'm going to use this
acronym and maybe you'll all know what
it is I had to have Ted explain it to me
w y SI wy g how many in the audience
know what that is
okay so the truth is I'm the new dean of
engineering and my background is in
physics so thank you so much Ted for
explaining that to me and we'll be
honoring Charles here on May 12th and
I'm not gonna tell him that I was the
only one in the room who didn't know
what that was these three newest heroes
join a very distinguished group that
includes Fred Terman Vint Cerf the
founders of Yahoo and google and a
former hero Martin Hellman actually is
here in the audience tonight he got his
Hero Award for his role in public key
encryption I've got that right so
welcome thank you for joining us now
unlike many award events the only thing
we ask of our honorees is to tell us how
they would like to spend their time on
campus and immediately before this
lecture Ted had I think a really fun
conversation over dinner with a small
group of Stanford engineering graduate
students we selected them to be experts
in areas that were dear to his heart and
he suggested tonight's talk to provide a
perspective on the influence of
semiconductor technology and to
emphasize the importance of technology
and technologists in helping the world
address current challenges so just let
me tell you just a little bit about the
impact microprocessors technologies had
on the world and how Ted came to play
such a large role in making it possible
just very briefly I think this is a very
well-educated audience so you know
microprocessors led to technologies like
computing cell phones the internet
things that we take for granted today
but it's not just that communications
and computing that have been transformed
you know chips are everywhere now
they're in our watches or telephones our
ATM machines our heart monitors barcode
scanners traffic lights dishwashers
children's toys they're everywhere
Ted's interest in electronics began when
he was 12 and his uncle gave him a
subscription to popular science
and from a catalog advertised in the
back of the magazine
he ordered a kit for building a
shortwave radio not long after that he
used a cathode ray tube purchased from
another catalog to build an oscilloscope
and so the seeds were planted for a
great career in electrical engineering
at age 16
Ted won a trip to Washington DC and a
$400 scholarship from the Westinghouse
Science Talent Search later during
summers away from college at Rensselaer
Polytechnic he worked for General
Railway signal company where he designed
two circuits that produced his first two
patents he came out west in 1955 to get
his master's I think he never left and
then his PhD in electrical engineering
at Stanford working with Professor
Bernie Woodrow who were delighted to
have in the audience tonight I believe
yes great thank you so much for coming
it was here at Stanford that Ted first
became interested in integrated circuits
six years after completing his PhD he
became employee number 12 at Intel he
was brought on board in 1968 by two
technology legends Bob Noyce and Gordon
Moore who together founded Intel an
earlier had founded Fairchild
Semiconductor one of the foundational
high tech companies in Silicon Valley
now while trying to simplify chips for a
calculator Ted came up with a solution
that involved a single general-purpose
processor chip rather than having to
require many custom-designed circuits
and he told us a little of that story
over dinner with co-inventors Frederico
Fagin and Stan Lazar he created created
what turned out to be the revolutionary
Intel 4004 the size of a fingernail the
microprocessor delivered the same
computing power as the first electronic
computer built in 1946 which filled an
entire room Ted has received numerous
awards the National Medal of Technology
and innovation was shared with Fagin and
Missouri he was named the first Intel
Fellow the highest technical position in
the company he received the 2011 I
Triple E RSC Wolfson James Clerk Maxwell
award
and has been named to the National
Inventors Hall of Fame and as a fellow
of the Computer History Museum tonight
we celebrate Ted as one of Stanford
Engineering's heroes and honor him with
this token of our imagination
congratulations Ted and I'm going to
turn this over to you and we'll give you
the token after your talk
thank you Thank You Dean drill for that
very kind introduction
I also want to thank all of you for
coming tonight especially my family you
got to consider they say I talk about
technology way too much at home so I'm
lucky that they would come tonight but
anyways my wife Judy two of our
daughters Lisa and Jill and five
grandchildren Hana Alex Pyle and thank
all the friends have come
I've been called various things in my
lifetime know few years back Intel ran
this ad you see I don't even see down at
the bottom I got a mention so I guess
that made me a rock star even though I
didn't have the funny clothes of the
long hair but more likely than not the
term that would be applied to me was
nerd or geek something along those lines
so being called a hero has a very nice
ring to it
Thank You Stanford now technology it has
been good for me
even before I got that subscription to
popular science magazine I was
interested in chemistry and even then it
turned out while I was working with
electronics
I was still staying with the chemistry I
mentioned I built the oscilloscope it
was a very auspicious time because this
was about 1949 1950 when television was
appearing on the market and so I even
ended up using that oscilloscope to fix
a few TV sets mostly for my family or
for for neighbors and even then it
turned out to be useful a little bit
later on now when it came time to go to
college I had to make a decision do I go
with chemistry or electronics now my
uncle the one who gave me that popular
science subscription was a chemical
engineer and he told me that the market
for in the chemistry professional
probably wasn't as good as that in
electronics so I figured let me go with
electronics this seemed like a lot of
fun and so I think it was probably the
right choice for me now I did my
undergraduate work at Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute in Troy New York I
grew up outside of Rochester New York
and that oscilloscope helped me get a
summer job at general Rayleigh Signal
Company and that actually led to a
couple of patents my senior year at RPI
I applied for and got a National Science
Foundation fellowship for graduate study
now I figured that fellowship was
probably a ticket to just about any
school in the country so why not go for
the best I applied to Stanford and they
took me now I arrived at Stanford in the
fall it was actually 1958 and I was
immediately impressed with Stanford RPI
was not that strong in solid-state
circuits
transistors and the like that summer job
that I'd had actually had me working
with transistors and when I started it
the junction transistor was maybe only
three years old so it was a real
opportunity but I come to Stanford and I
find out not only do are they stronger
they've just added to the faculty one of
the world experts a fellow named John
Moll I rushed to take his course and
sign up for it
and I think that was probably the first
time where ever had a clue as to what
was going on inside those devices but it
was really really a good course that was
also a good time to come to California
1959 saw three very important patents
filed now the first one Jack Kilby Texas
Instruments on the integrated circuit
but his patent really didn't cover the
way we make integrate
Serkis today it had some elements but
two patents issued filed by Fairchild
employees one by Jean Rene the other by
Bob Noyce the plane our process is
basically the way they make integrated
circuits and Bob Noyce patented the
integrated circuit so as I mentioned I
arrived at Stanford in 1958 and the
first part is the master's degree so the
next year
got to choose a thesis topic and having
had that railway signal job I realized
that railroads had a terrible time
keeping track of rolling stock and so I
raised the issue could we possibly build
a system where we would read the serial
numbers off railroad cars as they went
rolling by and I was told have we got
the guy for you
Bernie Woodrow just arrived in MIT and
the specialty was pattern recognition
and adaptive systems and we started
working together and here it is 155
years and still still working together
so anyway I got my PhD in 1962 and it
was in that area now I'd like to point
out a little bit something I probably
could not have afforded to go to
Stanford if it hadn't been for that
fellowship
it paid Stanford's tuition which was one
thousand and five dollars for a three
quarter year I've heard rumors to the
effect it's somewhat higher today is
that good
it also paid a modest living allowance
so he could probably save for those four
years I was on the dole but since
getting that PhD I've had pretty good
income and I pay income tax on that
income
so what percentage of it should I
attribute to the PhD say half of it even
if it's just half I figure over the
years I have repaid that fellowship
several hundred times over so it should
be pointed out government support of
education pays off even for the
government after I got my PhD I stayed
on doing research supported by
government contracts and that was for
six years and then I got a telephone
call the caller introduced himself Bob
Noyce I heard the name in fact I'd met
him once before there was a time when we
were told we'd have some important
visitors coming to the lab and could we
put on a demo and we had a speech
recognition demo we did Bob Noyce was in
that group so was David Packard so were
Sherman Fairchild and I believe Fred
Terman was there as well so anyway Bob
told me he was starting a new company
and would I be interested in talking to
him about a possible position in the
company I was 1968 when Intel was
founded now the new company didn't have
a place to meet
sorry interview at Bob Noyce is home I
didn't know what his new company would
be involved but remember he was one of
the inventors of the integrated circuit
so I figured it would have something to
do with integrated circuits and so in
the interview he asked me what did I
think the next big area for integrated
circuits would be now there are used to
be a researcher who had come from
Fairchild to talk to us about students
that were finishing their programs in
our lab his name was Rex rice and when
he visited to find out whether any
student would be appropriate for
Fairchild I used the opportunity to find
out as much as I could
about what was going on in the
semiconductor industry and I had done
some work both in the summer job and at
Stanford with the memory technology of
the day which was magnetic cores and it
seemed to me they were the worst part of
any computer project so when Bob asked
the question I thought about I answered
memory and what a lucky guess it was
because that's what he and Gordon had
decided their new company was going to
do so it helps to be curious about some
of this stuff so anyway the company has
started and they developed two new
processes gonna start the memory
business but there was some concern the
computer companies were used to using
this core memory they were pretty
comfortable with it they'd gotten the
bugs out of it so it might be awhile
before they'll adopt the new technology
and Intel any have three million dollars
in financing so that was a potential
problem as well but anyway in the
interview I even had to decide or
shortly after do I leave this
comfortable position at Stanford and go
to this perhaps risky startup that these
two people there had great reputations
so hopefully they could be successful
but $3,000,000 didn't sound like all
that much because what if they went
through the money before they had a
product on the market what happens then
but I was young enough and I think it
probably worth the risk and so I
accepted the job offer and became
employee number twelve had Intel well
anyway because they were concerned that
it might take a while for the memory
market to grow and they decided to do
some custom work and one of the custom
projects was for a company that sold
calculators under the name busy calm
that was one of the calculator models
that busy Khan made and an agreement was
signed in April of 1969 and it would be
for sick
mm calculator chipsets the chipset
should cost less than $50 a kit so at
the point we agreed to Thessaly might
call an attentive agreement we did not
have the specification for the chipset
it was about two months later in June of
1969 when a team of three Japanese
engineers arrived with their
specifications and I was assigned
liaison duty not designed just liaison
help them transfer their design
hopefully I knew enough about the
company to know who they should talk to
if they had a particular question so
being a curious type I'd like to learn
as much as I could about was being
transferred and the more I learned the
more concerned I became and so I took my
concerns to Bob Noyce who I reported to
at the time their books out the claim
that's not true but Bob is who I
reported to and Bob did what I think any
the stew CEO would do I mean if he finds
out there's a problem with the potential
contract he might walk away from it
Mike plow ahead and risk going bankrupt
or maybe try to get it fixed and he
asked me could I look at it and see if
there was anything we could do to maybe
simplify it and make this chipset more
compatible with Intel's capabilities and
that led to what I called the MCS for
project or concept it looked like it was
going to be about a dozen chips and 36
to 40 lead packages and at that time
those packages were quite expensive for
the for our technology so for the next
two months sort of played with a number
of ideas and it did seem to me there
were many ways that the chipset could be
simplified mostly by making the the
design underlying you might say
computation engine much more primitive
very Elementary and making it much more
programmable than the original had been
and finally we had it far enough along
so that as of September of 1969 we made
a formal proposal our director of
marketing wrote a letter to Japan
suggesting that they should consider an
alternate design to what their engineers
were proposing that led to a meeting the
management of the calculator company
came to California and received two
presentations one by their engineering
staff and one by myself and colleagues
and we emphasized at that time how much
more versatile our design would be have
applications well outside of calculators
and they chose to go with the Intel
design so we were committed as roughly
October 1969 to have what ultimately
would be the first microprocessor
working parts were available early in
1971 but even though we had working
parts there was no plan at that point to
make them anything other than a product
for this Japanese calculator company
busy calm and busy Khan was getting
itself into some financial difficulties
so there might not even be a market
there but those of us on the engineering
staff at Intel began to realize whenever
we had a design problem these devices
would be a tremendous help so we began
to approach marketing and say this
should become a standard product for
Intel and they said oh no you'll you'll
offend the big computer companies they
won't like it and they'll buy memory
from somebody else but we continued to
argue and the main argument we made was
it won't necessarily be competition for
the bigger computer companies it's a new
market and we look for applications that
use small amounts of memory because of
used a lot of memory it didn't make much
sense to go to a microprocessor you'd
have a better
and we'll talk about that in a few
minutes and we found lots of potential
applications things like control of an
elevator or control of a traffic light
I mean traffic light at an intersection
your VoIP robably have four sensors you
have to keep track of so there were
turned out to be lots and lots of
applications ultimately that became
known as embedded control and even to
this day I think the media does not seem
to be very well aware of embedded
control and I like to point out to
people that I am an example of embedded
control I have a cardiac pacemaker with
a microcontroller in it in me so how do
we get this product announced turned out
in the summer of 1971 there was a
shake-up in marketing a new marketing
director came in named ed gehlbach and
he was not nearly so frightened of
offering the microprocessor as an Intel
product and so as of November of 1971 we
ran this ad in electronic news was
actually November 15th the day the fall
joint computer conference opened in Las
Vegas now people have said did you know
what you had I say this is not a modest
Proclamation than the SAP
now as I said Intel's goal was memory
semiconductor memory to replace magnetic
cores and in January of 1970 Intel's
director of marketing and I co-authored
an article and had this graph in it in
which were predicting the cost of
semiconductor memory will be less than a
penny a bit by 1972 and we figured then
we'll take over from those magnetic
cores they probably couldn't do them for
a penny a bit now stop and think about
it if you were trying to build a
personal computer let's say on which you
would like to write a letter the letter
one typewritten page is probably in the
order of three or four hundred dollars
worth of memory and so if you want to
write a 10-page letter and have it all
in the computer now we're talking
thousands of dollars so again because of
that reason we were not looking for big
memory applications we're looking for a
little because if a company were let's
say had a situation where they needed
let's say four thousand dollars worth of
memory they could build a very high
power processor for a couple of hundred
dollars maybe they'd get the
microprocessor for twenty so you'd have
either let's say a four thousand and
twenty dollar computer or a four
thousand and two hundred dollar computer
the difference being that the four
thousand two hundred dollar computer
runs 20 or 30 times faster so that's why
memory didn't make sense big memory
didn't make sense for micro proc and
that's why we weren't looking at
personal computers in those days but
let's step forward to today you go out
today and you want to buy memory for
digital camera whatever you get more
like a hundred million bits of memory or
more for every penny you spend and
unlike the memory now much of it can be
non-volatile
the access time is much faster so we
have these little gadgets that means
sometimes they worry you drop them
through a crack on the floor they're so
small and solid-state disk drives for
our computers the progress that's been
made in semiconductor technology is
absolutely enormous our first
microprocessor the 4004 had just a
little over two thousand I think the
actual number was maybe 2,300 and the
typical operation and it took place in
about a microsecond and one instruction
would take something like ten of those
microsecond steps today your
microprocessor may have billions of
transistors on it and runs at several
thousand operations per microseconds so
that's billions of operations per second
and so a computer that would have maybe
filled a whole building back in 1970
couldn't offer the kind of performance
of the processor that maybe in a
smartphone that you can slip in your
pocket so it is amazing the technology
now people may have heard of Moore's Law
Gordon Moore coined who came up with
that phrase actually before Intel was
founded he was still a Fairchild
predicting that integrated circuits
would double in complexity every year -
and that's been followed almost as this
day the way it's happened primarily is
by making things smaller and we may be
coming toward some limits on them so we
don't know how much more progress
they'll be but look at some of the
computer applications that have been
made possible by all of that tremendous
advances in semiconductor technology the
smartphone's
digital photography internet access and
so on but we also have models for
various processes but I think we can
probably do an awful lot more there's
also work going on today in medical
research that make use of computer
application
mapping of the human genome and using
that information to tailor-make medical
treatments particularly in the case of
the diseases like cancers and so on
another area would be modeling of all
sorts of processes improving our ability
to model the atmosphere weather
prediction and things of that nature so
there are an enormous number of computer
applications that have been developed
but I think there's still a lot more
that can be developed now the same time
we've got all of these powerful
computers in fact even raises some
issues about how we do the design the
most of this work has been sort of
evolutionary the second microprocessor
we did was almost in parallel with the
four thousand force called the eight
thousand eight came out in early 1972 we
got feedback from that made some process
changes some and that led to the 8080
microprocessor which came out around
1974 the 8080 was probably the first
processor microprocessor that had
performance comparable to one of the
larger computers such as a mini computer
and feedback from that led to the 80 88
and the 8086 and the 80 88 was the basis
for the IBM PC and then there were not
subsequent generations the 286 the 386
and Pentiums each one built on the prior
architecture so you might say we've had
this evolutionary process and
everybody's running their stuff on this
super souped-up 8008 the question I
would ask someone in the business today
if we were to start from scratch with
this enormous technology is the computer
that we would build look anything like
what we're actually building that that's
the question I think needs to be asked
no computers can be used for a number of
things and they one of the things that
they end up being used for is modeling
and we have models that indicate that
some of the things that we've been doing
may be causing problems and for example
for about two or three hundred years now
we have been conducting an experiment
with this planet of ours we have been
taking carbon in various forms which has
been buried underground for many
millions of years and pulling it out of
the ground and dumping it after we burn
it dumping the products into the
atmosphere and the models that we have
indicate that is a risky proposition at
the same time that we're doing this you
look at the last century we had a
population growth on this planet of
about four times from about one point
five or six billion up to over six
billion people that population growth
tends to lead to things like destruction
of rainforests as people move in to take
out and they cut down the trees and
those rainforests are one of the things
that helps remove carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere so it's not only are we
dumping the stuff in there we're
destroying the drain that cleans it not
only did we have population growth but
we nearly doubled the average lifespan
of a human being at the beginning of
last century it was a little over 40
years at the end of the century it's
nearly 80 years so again an enormous in
fact it's interesting to do a bit of a
calculation
the last century was actually the last
century of a millennium we switched from
the ones as the first digit of the year
to two suppose we were to continue that
propagate population growth for another
millennium how much land would there be
on earth for each human being it would
be less than the area of the soles of
their feet there would be nothing left
on earth except people which also raises
problem what else is there to eat except
other people so something has to change
there but the impact of global climate
change is also of concern if we melt the
polar ice caps
that's leads to a sea level increase
that reduces the amount of land we have
available and a large part of the
world's population lives close to the
ocean we also see acidification of the
ocean and changes in climate change
which may lead to droughts so one of the
questions I would like to ask is is this
a recipe for doom or a recipe for
opportunity in fact going to biofuels so
that any co2 that we add to the
atmosphere had been taken out previously
by the growth of that fuel in fact along
those lines I might like to point out
was mentioned that Washington trip 61
years ago the project that I had was the
concept if we run out of fossil fuels
can we collect carbon dioxide react it
with hydrogen and recreate fuels
equivalent to fossil fuels so then we'd
have a
Society I wasn't thinking of much about
the damage to the atmosphere but just
the fact that those resources were
finite but it seems to me this would be
a reasonable area to do some research
today it is even more important as we
realize the impact of that carbon
dioxide more use of solar energy and
ways of getting better efficiency and at
our home we put in a photovoltaic system
has been one of the best financial
investments I've made in quite a while
and I think of other Californians come
to the same conclusion there will be
more of these put in and the more we put
in the lower the cost comes eventually
we'd like to see the day when we don't
have to be pulling coal or gas out of
the ground to generate electricity but
we do it that way
and as I mentioned the synthesis of
fuels another area we're facing drought
may or may not be caused by what we're
doing to climate change but that may be
a factor desalination of seawater would
seem to be a real possibility in other
words it's still looked at is a bit too
expensive but that's partly because of
the energy cost if we can find ways to
generate energy at a lower cost we very
likely can reduce the cost of
desalinating sea water and we've got a
lot of ocean right off our shores here
so we shouldn't have to worry about
about the source of water if we can do
desalination so I raised the issue
shouldn't we be doing more to promote
research and entrepreneurship in these
areas and I say spread the Stanford
model if we could look back to the days
of Fred Terman he created what I think
was one of the most unique environments
ever this relationship between the
University and local business to get the
concepts that were developed in the
university out into the marketplace and
that I think is one of the things maybe
more than anything that helped create
this economic powerhouse that we like to
refer to as Silicon Valley so
let's let's keep the spirit of Fred
Terman life and one of the concerns I
have with the changes and the
improvements that we're making in
lifespan if we destroy this planet let's
say in the next hundred years there may
be people in this room that would be
impacted such as my grandchildren thank
you so that is willing to take some
questions so we are now open for some
questions from the audience
parts of the talk yes professor Hoff you
mentioned that in the early 1960s along
with Professor winter you had developed
an algorithm the LMS algorithm that
leads me to believe that you must have
been using a computer in the early 1960s
can you talk about your earliest
experiences with computers yes okay I
can tell it's several early experiences
the first one was at the summer job the
company had a computer they used for
inventory and at one point needed to get
a relay and you could either fill out a
box of cards or with the specs you
wanted and send it off in a day later
you'd get a response and it may or may
not be what you wanted or you could go
to this guy in this one room who lose
the entire inventory and ask him and get
the answers immediately so that didn't
look good but when I came to Stanford
with Bernie Woodrow he managed to
persuade the powers-that-be
and boy they were hard to persuade to
let us get an IBM 1620 computer and
that's the first one I got the program
and if you think about the four thousand
for the target speed for it was just
about equivalent to the IBM 1620 one
decade later this question check was
just a reminder in the winter of 72 you
were helping Bernie
with his biomechanical project slab and
I remember you bringing it I was sitting
in on it you brought in an entire case
and you said I've got the equivalent of
a 16 20 computer in here just a student
I might point out the 16 20 we had it on
a special discount so we got it a very
favorable price and it cost $2,500 a
month to have that machine you think of
the computer you get today and you pay a
certain amount once and I think you've
got it yes very evolutionary child of
the eight thousand eight and you also
praise the question if we have the
semiconductor technology we have today
and we didn't start with the eight
thousand eight what kind of machine
architecture would be built with you
have any answers yourself to that
pleasure speculation so there are a
number of questions along that line like
one of the issues I think with the way
memory is today availability of flashman
why in fact why do we need what we call
an operating system I look at what's an
operating system do for us well there's
resource allocation well we put multiple
processors on one chip these days why
not just commit one of them to do
resource allocation and not even bother
the rest of the system with those
details but any application send a
request and say I need this and the
thing will decide you've got the
priority to get it or not the other part
is to make the interface what you want
it to look like why don't we design it
the right way in the first place
and I'm old enough to remember when you
turned on a radio you had to wait
several minutes for the filaments and
the tubes to warn you up there's still
an awful lot of computers out there that
you turn them on and you have to wait a
minute for something to be loaded saying
why doesn't in fact when the transistor
radio first appeared one of the big
selling points instant-on just turn it
on and it was playing why are
all computers that way today other
questions yes most ancient battles that
you helped to create with the eternal
war between the hardware guys and the
software within your own team that was
designing the 4000 for what was their
background were they coming at the the
architecture and the design mostly from
the standpoint of well let's figure out
what's gonna be convenient the program
or let's figure out how we do it with
the fewest transistors and how did you
balance those in the first round of the
eternal I don't know if other people
could hear the question but sort of the
battle between hardware and software
decisions well first of all an awful lot
of the 4004 was just me those two months
between June and September of 1969 and
having done extensive programming on an
IBM 1620 and then later an IBM 1130 and
I started playing around with a PDP 8
computer at Intel for another
application it seemed to me that as I
was trying to solve the calculator
problem and coming up a little computing
engine I was programming it at the same
time so that pretty much avoided what
you might call a conflict because I
would design the thing in such a way
that it was easy for me to program so
later on those decision may have been
may have been different
when when we did the 8008 the design for
that device the OP the instruction set
so it came from an outside source
however the instruction set had been
chosen in a way that looked like it was
meant to be implemented with a
relatively simple architecture and based
on the experience we had and the design
that we had already been doing for the
4004 it looked very reasonable to
suggest
they do that as a single chip so that's
how that happened I might point out
later on the fellow who came who came to
Intel was asking for a memory chip and
it was actually Stan maser who worked
with me was talking to the fella and
said you know if you consider doing that
whole processor is one chip not just the
metric ship and as Stan like to say he
nearly fell off his chair but anyway
later on he would go to say he brought
the idea for the microprocessor to into
a lot lots of claimants along those
lines but but we had already launched
the 4004 at the time he arrived but that
I think the the issue of of difficulty
of programming probably becomes more
important as you get to the more
advanced architectures and that's that's
a case where I'm not sure that the it's
really been answered now some of these
machines are pretty pretty complicated
and even within the architecture of the
Machine the operations that are going on
take they take a lot of work there's
lots of things like conditional
execution in other words you you may
pull several instructions at once and
try to execute the ball and you and then
you realize halfway through a wait I
shouldn't have done that one because it
needs the result of this other one so
you backup all sorts of stuff like that
that makes the design of these things
just incredibly complex yes
the the first the first four thousand
fours that came out were reported there
didn't seem to be working at all and and
it was mentioned federico for jean was
the one doing the testing on those he
was the one who laid them out
and he said he was really really
discouraged and then he looked at the
tip under the microscope
and they had missed one processing step
in the making good chip so that's why it
was totally dead so they ran another run
and these pretty well worked aspect so
yes in the back do you think that
advances in neuroscience will affect you
here architecture over the next decade
or do
do you think advances in neuroscience
--is will affect a computer architecture
over the next decade or two you know
it's I'm probably not the one to talk to
you probably should ask Bernie Woodrow
over here he's the expert in that field
and you can probably tell you where
where it's going though the one the
there were some areas that look to me to
be very interesting but I haven't
tracked where the research is going like
it was back I think in the mid or late
80s that the Defense Agency DARPA
sponsored a study of the current state
of research into you know neural net
neural net simulation and other work in
that field and some of it even included
studying the you know organisms behavior
and learning phenomena within living
organisms and things of that nature that
looked to me like a really interesting
area for research but I haven't stayed
in touch with it to see you know if they
really learned anything and fine find
anything that can then be adapted into
the design of equipment that we might
actually build but that probably should
pass that one to Bernie
do you want to try to answer it's a work
in progress working progress okay other
yes so what do you think can be achieved
with the artificial intelligence and
what limits may exist what do you think
can be achieved with artificial
intelligence and what limits may exist
well one of the one of the big
disappointments to me as all of this
progress that's been made in computers
and yet if you want to make a computer
you know do your bidding you pretty much
have to learn one of its languages they
don't understand human natural language
and it would seem to me that's an area
that I'd like to see more research done
in other words so that the computer will
become almost more like a companion in
other words and not something that you
have to learn Java or a C or C++ or
something like that and but that that's
one area that I think could be useful
there's another aspect that there was
work going on some years back and again
I haven't followed it that closely to
see whether it's changed but it was sort
of like artificial intelligence based on
sets of rules and the typical experiment
would involve let's say maybe a hundred
or a thousand rules and I would argue
that if the average human being has a
vocabulary that's probably more like
20,000 to 50,000 words and even each of
those words may have multiple meanings
that if we do rule-based processing as a
human being my guess is we have to have
more like a million or
or rules to handle all the situations
and they used to say if you were
learning a foreign language unless you
reached a threshold of somewhere around
5,000 words you would be considered
incompetent in that language there's
sort of like some magic numbers you have
to reach before you're actually
considered competent so before one of
these artificial intelligence rule based
machines was going to be I think it's
probably going to have to have upwards
of a million rules and that's gonna take
a while to program we have time for one
last question here first of all I want
to thank you for this wonderful story
and the talk I'm been a student for many
years of the history of the
microprocessor so really telling the
video I wanted to see what you what your
thoughts are when it comes to quantum
computers and the quantum processors
thank you what a terrific last question
okay well there's a couple a couple of
things I haven't done that much studying
of it but first of all consider that we
have been doing shrinking of integrated
circuits might say it started around
1974 there was a researcher at IBM and
some of his colleagues published an
article proposing that they make the
circuits smaller at the time they did
that the typical feature size was called
5 microns the micron is what a twenty
five thousandth of an inch so five
thousandth of an inch was the resolution
that's in nanometers that's five
thousand nanometers he was proposing
going to 1,000 nanometers and the idea
being it's a printing process you're
printing the circuit on a piece of
silicon make it 1/5 the linear dimension
that's 125th of the area you get 25
times as many circuits on that piece of
silicon and it turns out they run 5
times faster so you're getting like a
hundred and twenty five times the bang
for buck well that's the game that's
been played now for since 1974 we're now
in the
10 to 20 nanometer range about a 500 to
1 reduction people are talking about
going maybe to seven but the spacing of
silicon atoms is about 1/5 of a
nanometer and the behavior of a
transistor is determined primarily by
impurities embedded within the silicon
so you get too few silicon atoms even
fewer impurity atoms and you start to
run into things where they're they're
not behaving the way you expect so
that's a limit and we've had this
relatively smooth you know shrinking
process if we try to go to an entirely
new methodology let's say quantum
computing there's two parts of it the
concern one is it's like a whole new
start from scratch process so it's not
likely to happen as neatly as the next
shrink does so so that's one of the
problems and the other thing is there
are some behaviors in quantum systems
where the very act of reading it
disturbs it and in some cases in a
rather unpredictable way so it's even
worse than a core memory where the act
of reading get always destroyed the
information okay well I want to thank
you very much we have a small gift for
you as token of our appreciation which
is a plaque to recognize you as our hero
you